Because no one has gone there.
Many explorers have tried, but they all died in the ice.
Could I be the first one to get there?
First one to reach the North Pole?
Son, it's pretty unlikely.
Several expeditions are underway now.
The others are getting ready.
Like that. Born too late, that's all.
I do. I guess I better get used to the coal.
I go all the way to the pole.
You'd risk your life for nothing.
The unknown is always a challenge.
A man wants to explore and discover what new lands are like.
No matter how difficult or bleak, anyway, the poles are magical.
Remember, the Earth revolves on an axis passing through its poles.
When at the North Pole, the cardinal points no longer exist.
Now what? Now what points?
Cardinal points, know that.
If you're facing north and to your right is east,
and on your left is the west and...
Absolutely right.
But suppose you're up at the North Pole.
Left, directions, or south?
East, you never lost.
Point in any direction, still south.
Feel like south going left.
Go to the right, it's south.
In front, behind, south, out.
Yeah, but there's another reason motivating explorers
to know what's at the poles.
Finding the northeast and northwest passages,
the shortest sea routes between Europe and Asia,
and between Europe and the Americas.
But are they open always?
You remember Bering had tried to answer that question.
Father!
What is it, Roald?
The bridge of Nansen crossed the Greenland Ice Cap.
Now he's looking for a sea route to the North Pole, Dad!
You're like a compass. You always point north.
1897, the first attempt to explore Antarctica, the South Pole.
The captain is a Belgian, Adrian de Gerlach.
His second-in-command, the Norwegian, Roald Amundsen.
He's 25, and it'll be his first voyage to the polar region,
Exactly opposite to the pole in the north.
The ice is closing in.
We should sail for home.
Yes, I believe you're right, Amos.
Take the channel, it's free!
It's bound here all winter.
But we've no warm clothes, and our supplies are short.
We'll just have to manage.
And quickly before the polar night.
Captain, mad as a hatter, look.
Doctor, take command of the ship.
Now go and get that man.
We'll cut our bed covers and make ourselves warm clothing.
It's for fuel.
We'll burn fat, Doctor, the fat of seals and penguins.
Begins now.
There isn't going to be any sun for three months.
Time Explorer has survived the glacial winter.
For Amundsen, it was a springboard to further exploits.
There, Helmer, a small fishing boat for sale, and the price is right.
Chance the light.
What would you do with it, Raul?
I'll find the Northwest Passage.
In that nutshell, you're crazy.
Include me out, well.
Too bad, I'll see about supplies.
today sir and what is it I'll tell you I need supplies for an expedition
everything we'll need yes and how many will you be six or seven and I'd say
five years long that'll be quite an order I want everything delivered to
captain Amundsen in the port I'll see to it sir a very good day to you sir
that I had 22 times captain Amundsen I've put in 22 boxes of tried biscuits a
A quantity of dried beef, 10 cod liver oil, 20 barrels of kerosene, 20 barrels of flowers.
That's fine. Figure it exactly. Then put it all on my account.
I'll pay you just as soon as I return.
When you return!
In this leaky bucket, you'll never come back.
Oh, no, no, no, no. You'll pay me here and now, and I have no credit.
Otherwise, I'll stand there.
You've no reason to worry. You'll get paid.
But now I'm busy. They're my dogs. Huskies. We'll need them, all right?
Good. Bring them aboard.
Helmer, what are you doing here?
Oh, just out for a walk.
They're splendid dogs.
They're used by Eskimos. You know all about them.
And if you come, you're in charge of them. You can train them.
We sail in that nutshell never.
On a trip? Oh, get him!
Captain, police are coming!
Oh, I have more important matters!
Stand by the cast-off! We're underway! Come on, Hellboy!
Wait a minute, all right.
This is beginning to violent.
Eskimos are friendly.
What? Speaking English?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Long time ago, when I was a young man, some Englishman came here.
So I speak it.
What happened to them?
Oh, that is me, dogs.
What, because they didn't have dogs?
Yeah, here in the far north, you need dogs to survive!
I have six of them.
Alright, let's see him.
I think he's our friend.
Go and get our dogs.
Mmm.
Oh, trained yet.
See that?
Yeah, we can help train him.
Use the whip with a great deal of precision.
Dog barely gets touched.
Damn, precision with the whip!
No, it takes great skill to be...
...sup.
And your dogs, you gotta feed 'em.
Nice big chunks of seal, fresh bear meat, that's best.
Here are boys, Dindins.
Heh heh, oh.
Guess they like him.
I should explain. With working dogs, there's a boss dog and a lieutenant.
You gotta respect the rank.
The rank?
Yeah, but he's not gonna say.
He is the boss, and he's next.
And he's the next in line.
They're wild, but disciplined.
Your clothes are too tight.
Make skins and furs to make other ones for you.
We'll begin with the big one. You will stand up.
Ouch.
Many skins to cover him.
We can hunt bear now that daylight has come.
The bear is tasty.
Years, and then, one day...
Use axes.
And grappling hooks.
...sailed around the North Pole going east and west, but no one has yet reached the pole itself,
and that turns into a real race to get there first.
In 1895, the Norwegian Nansen has to abandon his ship trapped in the ice just 450 kilometers from his goal,
and he goes on by kayak.
In 1896, the Swedish explorer Solomon André made another attempt in a hot air balloon and died on the way.
In 1890, Louis Amadei of Savoy came to within 400 kilometers of the pole and disappeared.
The American Admiral Robert Perry organized eight successive expeditions.
You may be sure Amundsen was in the race.
Mr. Amundsen, this is a surprise.
It is an honor to serve you, Captain.
As I recall last time, you sent the police after us, sir.
I was young and impetuous.
What can I say?
Yes, well, now I'm here to settle the debt.
Roll square.
Well, that is, I believe that you've forgotten my compound interest, sir.
Interest on interest?
Compound interest.
But, Mr. Amundsen, it's been such a long time, and time is money.
Oh!
For your next expedition, I am ready to serve you, sir.
Biscuits, dried meat, salted carrots, sugar flour, anything at all!
Expedition, we've had enough.
We've no intention to go on more expeditions.
I mean, you've discovered the Northwest Passage.
No one's reached the Pole yet, and who knows, I could be the first.
But Robert Perry's on his way, and Frederick Scott as well.
The Pole, you realize, six months of darkness, maybe you'll freeze.
No, sir, not me. Oh, no, may heaven fall.
Oh, I say that's a good omen.
The fram, another leaky old tub. It's all rotten. Somebody ought to chop it up and burn it from firewood.
Come and take a look. Look at what.
I'll show you. It's built to withstand Arctic ice. The hull can be reinforced, and I'll put in a diesel engine.
Never! You understand? I am never taking this through Arctic ice. May heaven, uh, fall on my head.
You see, I'll go up the coast of Greenland. I'll be icebound in winter, and the ice flows north.
May heaven fall...
The pole?
Homer, it's not heaven.
A bulb.
That's all.
All right, Roald.
I'd like to manage the huskies.
If you like, I'll go part of the way.
You understand?
Sure, sure, I understand.
In one month, everything will be ready.
It was for you, Mr. Amundsen.
The North Pole has been conquered.
It's what?
Hey, period.
Wanted to be the first one.
Of course.
It's the other challenge.
You said you'd supply us on our next expedition.
We're going to the North Pole.
We'll need all this.
Biscuits, fuel oil, dried meat, flour, cooking oil, paraffin, oil for lamps, explosives,
Weapons, ammunition, six dog sleds, 25 pair of skis, one prefabricated house, five pigs, six sheep, a cat to chase rats, and what was the last thing?
Oh, yes, dogs. Where are the huskies? Huh?
Right, Helmer, how many have you got? A hundred?
For the North Pole, they're the best you can get.
Perfect.
We are going to the North Pole, aren't we?
Yes, of course. Where else would we go?
Peterson said he was going to sail through the Bering Strait to the west of Alaska.
He said it was going to save time since his earlier voyage seemed interminable to him.
He planned a course to the southwest right here, past South America, and then back up to the Pacific, heading toward the north.
And presto, here he is on the equator.
I'm on deck. Gotta see this.
First time across, you're initiated.
To Neptune, Sudden Hemisphere.
I'd better tell you, I've got another little surprise.
Oh yeah? What's your surprise?
We're not going to the North Pole.
What?
We're going to the South Pole. Robert Perry's been to the North Pole, right? We'll be the first ones to get to the South Pole.
But Robert Scott, a British officer, is already on his way.
Then we'd better hurry. The race is on.
And Amundsen headed for Whale Bay.
Already on the ice.
And Amundsen are about 1,400 kilometers away now.
In summer, Amundsen chose his best husky.
Scott is using Manchurian ponies, used to the cold, and a motorized sleigh.
Yeah, but which one is going to win?
In April, the polar night begins.
We have two months to put supplies along our route to the pole.
We'd better begin now.
Turn now.
Sun's going below the horizon.
We aren't going to see it again for four months.
It's fine.
Red tents are more visible, and could be warmer.
Ha ha!
It's hard to teach you!
Oh! Oh!
We've lived...
...was months long. Today we'll see the sun.
Sunny day was pretty short.
We've waited six months. Now let's go.
Mark!
There's 6,000 meters in altitude.
We have to find a passage.
That way.
Over there.
He's a sweat and frozen.
Now they can't move.
Destroy them.
Sound.
Two hundred and forty leagues.
Straight ahead.
Nine degrees, thirty-five minutes.
We're almost there.
It's ironic. All I'd ever thought of was the North Pole.
Now I'm as far away as I can be.
Great!
Flag, they beat us to it.
Let's take the picture, then we'll return.
Captain Scott and his men arrived at the South Pole one month after Amundsen,
but like so many other explorers before them,
who had bravely faced polar ice and snow and piercing glacial winds,
none of these men returned.
Today at the South Pole, there is in their honor a base named Amundsen Scott.